las horribles imágenes e historias que
salen de varias ciudades ucranianas como
lucha en cercanías de kiev tras la
retirada de las tropas rusas dan
testimonio de la crueldad de la guerra a
una escala que recuerda las barbaries de
camboya los balcanes y la 2ª guerra
mundial con las revelaciones de más de
300 cadáveres de civiles en la comunidad
internacional ha condenado lo que ha
sido calificado como crímenes de guerra
en los que señala a moscú como
responsables el kremlin y niega toda
implicación y denuncia un montaje por
parte de los ucranianos para manchar su
ejército el presidente de ucrania
volodymyr selenski denunció que se está
perpetrando un genocidio contra el
pueblo de ucrania y el líder de la casa
blanca- joe biden dijo que putin debería
enfrentar un juicio por crímenes de
guerra sin embargo abogados
internacionales advierten que el camino
para responsabilizar penalmente al
presidente ruso y otros altos líderes es
largo y complejo para ello entonces
quiero saludar en este momento a su
primer invitado del día el es luis
moreno-ocampo ex fiscal de la corte
penal internacional
louis por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 pregunto cuáles son
los crímenes de guerra y qué
características tienen estos crímenes
para ser considerados como tales
durante la guerra se puede matar donde
dos enemigo combatiendo
lo que no se pueden matar civiles eso es
un crimen de guerra también hay un
crimen tema de crimen de lesa humanidad
que puede estarse cometiendo durante la
vez que no hace falta es una guerra
criminal es humanidad es un ataque
masivo o sistemático a la población
civil esos son los crímenes que la corte
penal internacional
está investigando ahora en ucrania
importante en su deseo de que la gente
entienda que no se puede hacer eso está
prohibido
después en este caso de las cosas
específicas usted menciona así como
ustedes mostraron reciben imágenes para
el tiempo antes faltan trabajo
diariamente ya o más para demostrar
quién mató esa persona y sobre todo
quién le ordenó porque la corte para
internacional no va a investigar un
soldado que mató una persona va a
investigar los crímenes más graves
entonces el tema es eso es una órgano de
extracción de un capitán de un teniente
general despotismo bueno es una corte
penal internacional de la investigar
claro
louis le quiero preguntar entonces cómo
se realiza esta investigación qué tan
difícil es llegar hasta el responsable
digamos sin ninguna duda poder señalar a
alguien cuánto se podría tardar además
una investigación como ésta teniendo en
cuenta que las partes se acusan
mutuamente
bueno es el crimen más grave que está
ocurriendo que no se puede investigar
enrollado el crimen de agresión es
escribiste muy fácil de probar google
docs obviamente el presente putin ordenó
la intervención militar en ucrania esa
ayuda es más fácil de probar pero
lamentablemente en el caso parte lola
rusia como está ocurriendo china que no
son miembro de la corte para que ese
crimen se investigue hace falta el
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
adopte una resolución pero como rusia o
estados unidos chinas tienen poder de
veto esa resolución y nunca se va a
adoptar por lo tanto escribe más fácil
de probar y tiene más obvio es el más
grave también el crimen de agresión no
se puede investigar se piense en irak
hay hubo 250.000 muertos como
consecuencia de la guerra no todo una
cura por infracción por un crimen de
guerra cometido por alguna fuerza la
mayoría son víctimas de la guerra
entonces el día más grave acá en la
guerra eso no se puede investigar
para probar la responsabilidad que
probar las muertes la el impacto un
agente arturo el desplazamiento y hay
que probar que siendo cometido al hecho
está por demás parte más complicada
tan difícil es es difícil pero
justamente una ventaja que tenemos ahora
es que hay una corte para internación
permanente establecida que tiene a capaz
de hacerlo el fiscal está muy activo el
fiscal de la corte penal internacional
está muy activo estuvo en ucrania el
aviso iba a ser imparcial él le pide
información a rusia entonces justamente
el temor que tiene a rusia de que sea
algo armado el fiscal puede investigarlo
y demostrar si hicieron la universidad
ahora sí sí sí tengo muchas preguntas y
el tiempo es corto entonces luis quería
preguntarles cuáles son las
posibilidades de que el público en
efecto sea su que sea juzgado como lo
pide el presidente de eeuu vayan bueno
el presente para que le quiera ayudar
además de hablar y decir es un criminal
de voy a acompañar el proyecto a la
corte estados unidos nunca ha mencionado
la corte internacional de problemas con
eso como estabilidad no quiere que la
corte investiga gente que no es miembro
de la corte entonces de una cultura
ambigua
de todos modos el cic ha estado pidiendo
evidencias hay muchos países que están
apoyando para pasar la evidencia
entonces depende del fiscal
que incidentes elige y aquí en una cosa
puede elegir accidentes más pequeños
donde un capitán que esté preso o bill
vaya a la corte internacional y lo
juzguen o puede elegir casos más
complicados y llegar a putin y puede
traer ese tema él cuando yo creo fiscal
intentamos de investigar darfur de forma
muy comprensiva estábamos dos años
aprendimos y cuando viene el caso
kadhafi lo que hicimos fue seleccionar
un grupo de hechos iniciales quedan muy
claros investigamos eso y en tres meses
tiempo una orden de arresto contra
gadafi su hijo saif y el jefe de
inteligencia libio así que el tema está
en manos del fiscal de la corte penal
internacional que arica
30 segundos 20 segundos mejor dicho para
esta última pregunta qué quiero hacer
qué pasa con estas investigaciones estos
procesos ya que rusia no reconoce la cpi
bueno acá en ucrania aceptó
entrar en una corte por eso para los
primas de guerra de lesa humanidad la
corte lo puede hacer de la corte puede
investigar los jueces deberán revisar la
evidencia y analizar si emite una orden
el resto del teo de cuestionar a quien
la resta quien no que están las personas
sospechadas pero cuando yo me estaba y
que nos comunicó cómo investigar sur
como vitro de arresto bueno el presente
va a ser en el momento en el presidente
de hoy está preso discutiéndose así lo
mandaron la corte ayer comenzó en la
haya el juicio al jefe las milicias que
ordenada que cometía el genocidio
entonces para tiempo que sabe pero la
real de la justicia llega al final pues
nos quedamos con eso entonces no hay
muchísimas gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 a usted